uh first of all what is a polynomial
time algorithm
yeah perhaps we could discuss that
so yeah let's let's actually just even
yeah that's
what is algorithmic algorithmic
complexity what are the major
classes of algorithm complexity so we
in in a problem like the assignment
problem or
scheduling schools or any of these
applications
you have a set of input data
which might for example be um
a set of vertices connected by edges
with
being you're given for each edge the
capacity of the edge
and you have algorithms
which are think of them as computer
programs with operations such as
addition subtraction
multiplication division comparison of
numbers and so on
and you're trying to construct an
algorithm
based on those operations
which will determine in a minimum number
of
computational steps the answer to the
problem in this case the computational
step
is one of those operations and the
answer to the problem
is let's say the
the configuration of the network that
carries the maximum amount of flow
and an algorithm is said to run in
polynomial time
if as a function of the size of the
input
the number of vertices the number of
edges and so on
the number of basic computational steps
grows only as some fixed power of that
size
a linear algorithm would
execute a number of steps linearly
proportional to the size
quadratic algorithm would be steps
proportional to the square of the size
and so on
and algorithms that whose running time
is bounded by some
fixed power of the size are called
polynomial algorithms
and that's supposed to be relatively
fast class of algorithms that's right we
theoreticians take that to be
the definition of an algorithm being
efficient and
we're interested in which problems can
be solved by such
efficient algorithms one can argue
whether that's
the right definition of efficient
because you
could have an algorithm whose running
time is the ten thousandth power of the
size of the input and that wouldn't be
really efficient and in practice it's
oftentimes
reducing from an n squared algorithm to
an n log n or a linear time
is practically the jump that you want to
make
to allow a real world system to solve a
problem
yeah that's also true because especially
as we get very large
networks the size can be in the millions
and uh
and then anything above uh
n log n where n is the size would be
uh too much for a practical solution
okay so that's polynomial time
algorithms what other classes of
algorithms are there
what's so that usually they they
designate polynomials of the letter p
yeah there's also
np np complete and be hard yeah
so can you try to disentangle those and
by trying to define them simply
right so a polynomial time algorithm is
one which
whose running time is bounded by a
polynomial
in the size of the input uh there's
then there's that the class of such
algorithms is
called p in the worst case by the way we
should say
right yeah for every case of the problem
and that's very important that
in this theory um when we measure the
complexity of an algorithm
we really measure the
number of step the growth of the number
of steps
in the worst case so you may have an
algorithm that
[Music]
runs very rapidly in most cases but if
there's
any case where it gets into a very long
computation
that would increase the computational
complexity by this measure
and that's a very important issue
because there
as we may have discussed later there are
some very important algorithms which
don't have a good
standing from the point of view of their
worst case performance
and yet are very effective so
so theoreticians are interested in p the
class of problem solvable in polynomial
time
then there's um np which is the class of
problems
which may be hard to solve but where the
where where when confronted with the
solution
you can check it in polynomial time let
me give you an example there
so if we look at the assignment problem
so you have n boys you have n girls
the number of numbers that you need to
write down to specify the
problem instances n squared
and the question is
how many steps are needed to solve it
and
um jack edmonds and i were the first to
show that it could be done
in time n cubed uh
earlier algorithms required n to the
fourth
so as a polynomial function of the size
of the input this is a
fast algorithm now to illustrate the
class
np the question is how long
would it take to verify that a solution
is optimal so for example
if if the input was a graph
we might want to find the largest
clique in the graph or a clique is a set
of
vertices such that any vertex each
vertex in the set
is adjacent to each of the others
so the clique is a complete subgraph
yeah so if it's a
facebook social network everybody's
friends with everybody else it's close
click no that would be what's called a
complete graph it would be
no i mean uh within that click uh within
that clique yeah
yeah they're all friends so a complete
graph is when
everybody is friendly as everybody is
friends with everybody yeah
so the problem might be to determine
whether in a given graph there exists a
clique
of a certain size
well that turns out to be a very hard
problem but how
but if somebody hands you a clique and
asks you to check
whether it is a hands you a set of
vertices and ask you to check whether
it's a clique
um you could do that simply by
exhaustively looking at all of the edges
between the vertices in the clique
and verifying that they're all there and
that's a polynomial time
that's a polynomial so the verify there
the problem of finding the clique
appears to be extremely hard but the
problem of verifying a clique
uh to see if it reaches the target
number of
vertices um is
easy to solve is easy to verify so
finding the clique is hard checking it
is easy
problems of that nature are called the
non-deterministic polynomial time
algorithms
and that's the class np
and what about mp complete and be hard
okay
let's talk about problems where you're
getting a yes no a yes or no answer
rather than a numerical value so either
there is a
a perfect matching of the of the uh
boys with the girls or there isn't
it's clear that um every problem in p
is also in np if you can solve the
problem
exactly then you can certainly verify
the solution on the other hand
there are problems in the class np
this is the class of problems that are
easy to check
although they may be hard to solve it's
not at all clear that
problems in np lie in p so for example
if we're
looking at scheduling classes at a
school
the fact that you can
verify when handed a schedule for the
school whether it meets all the
requirements
that doesn't mean that you can find the
schedule rapidly
so intuitively np non-deterministic
polynomial
checking rather than finding um
is going to be harder than
is going to include is easier checking
is easier and therefore the class of
problems that can be checked
appears to be much larger than the class
of problems that can be solved
you